Dans la portion du passage que nous avons lu, c'est-à-dire du verset 9 jusqu'au verset 20,
et aujourd'hui on va finir le chapitre 6,
nous sommes dans une transition dans l'Épitre aux Hébreux, dans une parenthèse.
C'est une transition entre la première partie du chapitre 6,
qui est certainement la partie la plus virulente de l'Épitre aux Hébreux,
la partie la plus dure de l'Épitre aux Hébreux,
et même peut-être une des parties les plus dures de tout le Nouveau Testament.
Où Jésus, au travers de son esprit, avertit les auditeurs à cause de leur paresse,
avertit les auditeurs du risque de l'immobilité spirituelle.
Vous auriez pu être des maîtres.
Et avertit du risque de l'immobilité.
C'est un passage qui est particulièrement virulent,
si bien que certains prennent peur en lisant ce passage,
et croient même à la perte du salut en lisant ces passages si violents, si virulents,
ces avertissements de la part de l'auteur.
Et nous sommes donc dans cette transition entre cette partie d'avertissement et de menace,
du verset 1 jusqu'au verset 8,
au cœur de l'Épitre, dans lequel nous arrivons bientôt,
courage, un peu de patience,
au sujet du sacerdoce de Christ,
c'est-à-dire Christ en tant que notre prêtre,
Christ en tant que souverain sacrificateur.
Et tout cela nous sera bien détaillé au chapitre 7.
Mais pour l'instant, nous sommes dans une transition de l'auteur,
qui, après avoir quitté ses vives menaces et avertissements,
nous conduit tranquillement, progressivement,
vers le sacerdoce de Christ.
Et quel est le but de cette portion,
de cette micro-portion du verset 9 au verset 20 ?
Eh bien, le but, il est explicité au verset 11,
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est toujours bon
de revenir dans le contexte du passage
pour ne pas nous perdre dans des détails
alors que le thème nous est explicitement donné.
Verset 11 du chapitre 6,
quel est le but de ce passage ?
Nous désirons que chacun de vous montre le même zèle
pour conserver jusqu'à la fin une pleine espérance.
Dieu veut que ces chrétiens soient confiants.
Dieu veut que les enfants, que ces enfants,
aient une pleine assurance.
Et c'est un sujet sur lequel notre génération a besoin d'être enseignée,
l'assurance.
Une génération frappée soit par un surplus d'assurance mal placée,
et les hypocrites sont les premiers à être pleins d'assurance,
en pensant qu'ils maîtrisent demain,
qu'ils contrôlent les choses,
et que même si un Dieu existait,
eh bien Dieu m'aime.
Parce que j'ai vécu pas la pire des vies,
parce que j'ai pu faire ces choses,
j'ai pu faire des pèlerinages,
j'ai donné aux pauvres.
Mais notre génération souffre aussi,
et particulièrement peut-être même dans les églises,
d'un manque d'assurance.
D'un manque d'assurance dans les promesses de Dieu.
Un manque d'assurance dans leur salut.
Et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous trouvons
six tant de chrétiens dans des situations anormales.
Des chrétiens affligés.
Des chrétiens abattus.
Des chrétiens constamment tristes.
Des chrétiens constamment craintifs.
Des chrétiens qui ne sont peut-être pas craintifs,
visiblement,
mais qui sont marqués par la timidité,
par un manque d'audace pour partager l'évangile.
Parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'assurance.
Parce qu'ils n'ont pas une pleine conviction
de leur espérance des choses à venir.
Oui, le manque d'assurance ne se traduit peut-être pas
dans notre vie par la tristesse, par l'affliction,
mais se traduit peut-être par une passivité,
un immobilisme.
Un manque d'assurance dans notre,
ce que la Bible décrit, notre espérance.
Et nous avons, nous étions longuement arrêtés
sur cette notion d'espérance.
L'espérance n'est pas quelque chose de conditionnel
pour le chrétien.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'il espère avoir.
Le salut n'est pas quelque chose que le chrétien
espère avoir, j'espère être sauvé.
L'espérance, selon le langage biblique,
est quelque chose d'assuré, de certain,
et ce n'est qu'une question de temps
avant qu'il les saisisse pleinement.
Voilà l'assurance du chrétien.
Et il est nécessaire pour le chrétien
et pour l'Église d'être enseignés
au sujet de la pleine assurance
qu'ils doivent avoir
au sujet de leur espérance.
Il est probable que certains d'entre nous
vivent sans cette espérance.
Cette espérance, elle est objective,
elle ne bougera pas.
Mais il est probable que certains d'entre nous
vivent comme si cette espérance
n'était pas si vraie que ça.
Ils la proclament de leurs lèvres,
mais la façon dont ils vivent leur vie
n'est en réalité visiblement pas si différente
des inconvertis,
de ceux qui vivent sans espérance après la mort,
sans certitude des choses éternelles.
En quoi votre vie est-elle si différente ?
Comment manifestez-vous votre conviction
de votre pleine espérance ?
L'intérêt de Dieu dans ce passage,
c'est que nous puissions être convaincus,
c'est que nous puissions posséder
une pleine assurance de notre espérance.
Et les causes
qui nous font oublier notre espérance
sont diverses.
Et même si le but de notre prédication
n'est pas de s'arrêter sur chacune de ces causes,
l'auteur va traiter certaines de ces causes
envers les Hébreux,
et ce sont des causes qui sont assez similaires
à ce que nous pouvons traverser aujourd'hui.
Le péché
peut nous dérober notre assurance.
Le péché peut nous dérober
cette conviction
de notre espérance éternelle.
Les tribulations,
les souffrances
peuvent causer dans notre cœur
une perte de perspective,
sur les réalités éternelles.
Une mauvaise théologie,
la perte du salut,
le fait que notre salut
soit conditionné par notre obéissance,
toutes ces choses-là
peuvent être des causes
de notre perte d'assurance.
Mais le but de ce passage,
c'est que nous puissions avoir
une diligence
pour cultiver notre assurance
envers l'espérance.
Je vais répéter,
il y a beaucoup de hans.
Le but de ce passage,
c'est que,
verset 11,
nous puissions cultiver
une diligence,
que nous puissions, pardon,
avoir une diligence
pour cultiver une assurance
envers notre espérance éternelle.
Relisons le verset 11 à nouveau.
Nous désirons que chacun de vous
montre le même zèle.
De quoi il parle ici,
l'auteur ?
De quelles mêmes ailes ?
Verset 10,
pour revenir,
pour bien comprendre
de quelles ailes il parle,
Dieu n'est pas injuste
pour oublier votre travail
et l'amour que vous avez montré
pour son nom,
ayant rendu
et rendant encore
des services au sein.
Donc là,
l'auteur est en train de dire
Dieu n'a pas oublié
tout ce que vous avez fait.
Vous êtes peut-être aujourd'hui
dans un état de...
Vous êtes en train de stagner.
Vous êtes peut-être
dans un immobilisme spirituel.
Vous n'avez pas beaucoup progressé
depuis des semaines,
depuis des mois,
depuis même des années.
Mais pour autant,
Dieu n'a pas oublié
vos premières heures
où vous avez manifesté
un amour,
un zèle pour lui.
Et Dieu a associé
à chacune des choses
que vous avez fait pour sa gloire
un lot de récompenses.
Et Dieu est juste
et il va vous l'attribuer.
Verset 11,
nous désirons que chacun de vous
montre le même zèle.
Qu'est-ce que l'auteur
est en train de dire ?
Il n'est pas en train de dire
j'ai envie que vous cultivez
le même zèle
et que vous continuez
à aider les saints
comme vous l'avez fait,
que vous continuez
à réconforter,
à manifester de l'amour
en vous rendant des services.
Ce n'est pas ce qu'il est en train
de dire ici l'auteur.
L'auteur,
il est en train de dire
le même zèle
que vous avez manifesté
lors de vos premières heures,
les heures les plus vives
de votre vie chrétienne,
appliquez-le maintenant
pour cultiver
votre assurance
pour l'espérance.
et ce matin,
mes frères et sœurs,
c'est un exercice,
l'écoute de la prédication.
Et le Seigneur,
nous sommes
d'avoir de la diligence
alors que vous écoutez
cette prédication
pour cultiver
l'assurance
de l'espérance éternelle
pour vos âmes.
Écoutez avec attention,
n'écoutez pas
de façon passive,
mais répondons
au commandement de Dieu.
Montrons le même zèle
que nous avons pu manifester
pour Dieu.
Montrons-le
et mettez-le en pratique
pour cultiver notre cœur,
l'assurance
de notre espérance.
Et pour ce faire,
eh bien,
qu'est-ce que l'auteur a fait ?
Dans toute la portion
sur laquelle nous étions arrêtés
pendant plusieurs prédications,
eh bien,
l'auteur a présenté
quelques arguments
imparables
de notre espérance.
Notre espérance est certaine
et elle est sûre
et je vais vous donner
quelques arguments
pour lesquels vous pouvez
vous reposer
dans votre espérance.
Et notez que dans tout ce passage
du verset 9 au verset 20,
eh bien,
l'auteur détourne le regard
du public paresseux,
du public lent,
en proie aux doutes
et il se concentre
sur Dieu exclusivement.
Vous voulez être assuré
de votre espérance ?
Regardez à Dieu.
Vous voulez être sûr
de la stabilité
de vos promesses ?
Cessez de regarder
à vous-même.
Regardez à Dieu.
Il est le fondement
de vos promesses.
Il est la garantie
Et dans tout le passage
que nous avons lu,
l'auteur s'est arrêté
sur des arguments
qui sont en réalité
imparables
et qui devraient suffire
pour nos âmes
pour être stables
dans notre foi,
pour être convaincus,
pour vivre,
comme les enfants disent,
pour vivre
comme si cette espérance,
elle était vraie.
Vivre ici-bas
avec la pleine assurance
de notre espérance.
Quels sont les arguments
que l'auteur a utilisés ?
Dieu a prêté serment.
Dieu s'est abaissé
au langage humain
et Dieu a juré
à Abraham
qu'il accomplira
sa promesse.
L'auteur a rappelé
l'immuabilité
de la résolution
de Dieu.
Le décret de Dieu
vous concernant,
peuple de Dieu,
est un décret éternel,
au-dessus du temps,
élevé au-delà
des circonstances,
des problèmes
que vous pouvez rencontrer.
Il est certain.
Dieu est immuable.
Il y a une impossibilité
ontologique
que Dieu mente.
C'est impossible
dans la nature de Dieu
que Dieu puisse mentir.
Est-ce que Dieu est incapable
de faire certaines choses ?
Oui.
Dieu ne peut pas mentir.
Et sur la base
de la nature de Dieu,
je veux que vous soyez assurés
de vos promesses éternelles
et que vous viviez
comme si elles étaient vraies.
voilà les arguments
imparables
que l'auteur
a utilisé
du verset 9
jusqu'au verset 19
jusqu'à arriver
à cette notion
d'espérance.
Cette espérance,
ce qui vous réserve
dans l'éternité,
c'est l'encre
de vos âmes.
Vous pouvez passer
par des tempêtes.
par des moments
particulièrement difficiles.
Mais vous avez
une espérance
qui agit
comme une encre
pour vos âmes.
Elle est sûre.
Elle est solide.
Voilà l'argument
de l'apôtre.
Vous avez des promesses,
mes frères et sœurs.
Si vous avez
embrassé Christ
par la foi,
vous avez des promesses
qui vous sont réservées.
Elles vous attendent.
Elles vous attendent
dès à présent.
Dieu,
et écoutez ce langage
si anormal
à nos oreilles,
mais Dieu vous le jure.
Dieu te le jure.
Des promesses pour vous
vous sont réservées.
Et chaque fois
que nos âmes
sont vacillantes,
chaque fois que nous sommes
en pro au doute,
nous ferions bien
de revenir à ces passages
et laisser notre cœur
être exposé
aux arguments imparables
de l'auteur
vis-à-vis de la stabilité
des promesses
qui arriveront
quoi qu'il arrive
pour nous.
Mais c'est dans le verset 20
que nous allons aborder
aujourd'hui
que nous allons voir
le bouquet final
de l'argumentaire
de l'auteur.
Il a présenté déjà
des arguments imparables,
mais c'est seulement
à la fin
de son argumentaire
que le doux nom
de Jésus
réapparaît enfin.
le fondement ultime
de l'espérance
de l'homme.
Et pour ceux
qui connaissent
l'épître aux Hébreux,
vous savez,
et j'aime à le dire,
que c'est un des épîtres
les plus christocentriques
des Écritures,
explicitement christocentriques.
Mais si vous avez lu
Hébreux,
vous seriez peut-être étonnés
que cela fait déjà
deux chapitres et demi
que le nom de Jésus
n'est plus réapparu.
L'auteur se tournant
et saumant
et parlant aux auditeurs
après de vives alertes,
après de vives avertissements
contre l'apostasie.
Et on peut imaginer
les auditeurs
pris d'effroi,
pleins de doutes.
Et maintenant,
le nom doux
et beau de Jésus
réapparaît enfin
pour la consolation
de l'âme de l'auditeur.
Voilà le bouquet final
de l'argumentaire
de l'auteur
qui vise à ébahir,
à captiver
l'âme de l'auditeur
pour qu'il puisse
enfin se reposer
dans les promesses
de son Dieu.
Enfin,
la deuxième personne
de la Trinité.
C'est le fondement ultime.
Après les fondements
déjà imparables
que l'auteur a présentés,
c'est le fondement ultime
de notre espérance.
Jésus-Christ
en tant que prêtre.
en tant que souverain,
sacrificateur,
c'est l'assurance
des assurances.
Et c'est significatif
que le nom de Jésus
apparaisse
à la fin
de l'argumentaire
de l'auteur
pour plusieurs raisons
et on ne va pas se lancer
sur toutes les raisons possibles.
Mais après avoir parlé
des promesses
du chrétien,
après avoir parlé
des promesses
qui vous sont sûres
et certaines,
eh bien,
le beau nom de Jésus
arrive à la fin
pour nous rappeler
que la promesse
des promesses,
c'est Jésus-Christ
lui-même.
Le chrétien
ne devrait pas tant être
s'arrêter
sur toutes les promesses
périphériques
à Jésus-Christ.
Jésus-Christ
est la promesse,
le cœur des promesses.
Il est la promesse
des promesses.
Et lorsque nous parlons
de l'espérance,
lorsque nous parlons
des promesses
sur estertaines,
eh bien,
sachons que le cœur
des promesses,
c'est Jésus-Christ
lui-même.
Et nous aurions tort,
comme c'est le cas
dans plusieurs églises,
de solliciter les auditeurs
avec plusieurs promesses
indéfinies,
personnelles,
non bibliques,
alors que la Bible
nous rappelle constamment
que la promesse
des promesses,
c'est Jésus-Christ
lui-même.
Et le fait que Jésus
arrive à la fin
de l'argumentaire
nous rappelle également
que toutes les promesses
qui sont vôtres
et qui sont vraies
et sur lesquelles
nous avons raison
de nous arrêter.
La présence du Christ
à chaque moment
de votre vie,
dans les moments
les plus difficiles,
votre sanctification
sûre et certaine,
votre corps
qui va ressusciter
un jour,
vous allez être glorifiés.
La provision de Dieu
chaque jour,
toutes ces promesses
reposent
sur Jésus-Christ
lui-même
et particulièrement
sur son office
en tant que prêtre.
toutes les promesses,
même la restauration
de ce monde
corrompu.
Et c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle
il garde ce nom
de Jésus
pour la fin.
Il est à la fois
le cœur des promesses
et il est le fondement
de toutes les promesses.
C'est l'argument
le plus efficace
que l'auteur va utiliser
pour encourager
les auditeurs,
pour consoler
les auditeurs.
et j'aimerais
que vous compreniez
la pertinence
de ce que l'auteur
est en train de faire ici.
Mes frères et sœurs,
ne laissez jamais
votre âme
ou ne laissez même
jamais un autre chrétien
penser que l'exposition
de Christ
est trop éloignée
de ses problèmes,
de son anxiété,
de ses craintes.
Ne laissez jamais
votre âme vous dire
« Ce n'est pas ce dont
j'ai besoin aujourd'hui. »
dans mon anxiété,
dans ma crainte.
L'auteur est précisément
en train d'élever
l'argumentaire
au nom de Jésus-Christ
pour que vous puissiez
être sûrs
et convaincus
de votre assurance,
de votre espérance
pour que vous puissiez
trouver la paix.
C'est précisément
ce que fait
l'auteur ici.
Enlevez Jésus
de ce chapitre.
de vos promesses.
Enlevez Jésus
du fondement
de vos promesses
et toutes les promesses
auxquelles vous vous attachez
tomberez du ciel
en un instant.
Certains espèrent
aller au ciel
sans même songer
à Christ
en premier lieu,
à retrouver Christ.
Certains attendent
la joie
après les larmes,
le repos,
la joie,
sans penser
à Christ
le cœur des promesses.
Mais enlevez Christ
du paradis,
vous vous retrouvez
en enfer.
Vous vous retrouvez
dans la présence immédiate
de Dieu
sans le trône
de la grâce.
Christ,
le cœur des promesses,
le fondement
de toutes les promesses.
Jésus-Christ
n'est pas seulement
celui qui présente
l'Évangile,
il est l'Évangile.
C'est la bonne nouvelle.
La bonne nouvelle,
c'est que l'homme
puisse être réconcilié
à Jésus-Christ,
être en communion
avec le bienfait suprême
de l'âme de l'homme,
Jésus-Christ lui-même.
Tout autre présentation
de Jésus-Christ
est blasphématoire.
Jésus-Christ
qui peut nous aider
dans notre vie seulement.
Jésus-Christ
qui peut nous aider
à nous faire rentrer
au paradis seulement.
Jésus-Christ
est le paradis.
La communion
avec Jésus-Christ,
c'est l'essence même
de notre vie éternelle.
Et nous devons
ranimer nos cœurs
dans cette compréhension
ce matin.
nous allons quitter
le rivage
de cette vie
dans cette méditation
en ayant considéré
l'espérance
comme l'encre
de nos âmes
et nous allons regarder
maintenant Christ,
le rocher des âges,
celui qui a porté
l'encre de notre espérance
dans le lieu très saint.
Nous allons élever
notre regard
sur cette chaîne
qui nous lie
à l'éternité
et nous allons considérer
celui qui se tient
dans le lieu
où nous nous tiendrons
un jour,
notre précurseur,
Jésus-Christ.
Dieu,
et voilà le message
central de ce passage,
de ce verset 20,
Dieu veut affermir
la conviction intérieure
du chrétien.
Dieu veut que tu sois sûr
de ton triomphe.
Dieu veut que tu vives
maintenant
à la lumière
d'un triomphe certain.
Et il le fait
par l'exposition
de l'office de prêtre
de la deuxième personne
de la Trinité.
Jésus-Christ.
Et nous allons voir
dans le verset 20
comment l'auteur
et Dieu au travers
de l'auteur
veut affirmer,
veut consolider
notre assurance
vers l'espérance
par l'exposition
de la prêtrise de Christ.
Premièrement,
par l'entrée de Christ
en tant que souverain
sacrificateur.
Comment l'entrée de Christ
nous assure le triomphe.
Deuxièmement,
par la disposition
de notre grand prêtre.
Comment le fait
que Christ est entré
pour nous
nous assure le triomphe.
Et troisièmement,
comment le rôle
de précurseur de Christ
nous assure le triomphe.
Voilà les trois points
sur lesquels
nous allons nous arrêter
dans ce verset 20.
Nous n'allons pas aborder
ce personnage mystérieux
de Melchisedec encore.
bientôt le chapitre 7
va nous le détailler
avec beaucoup plus
de détails
et nous aurons le temps
d'y revenir.
Mais pour l'instant,
laissons-nous encourager
dans notre assurance.
Laissons-nous encourager
dans notre espérance
par la considération
de l'office de Christ
en tant que prêtre.
Premièrement,
lisons à nouveau
ce verset 20
et peut-être ce verset 19
pour introduire ce verset 20.
Cette espérance,
nous la possédons
comme une encre de l'âme
et nous avons fait
une prédication
sur ce passage-là,
sûre et solide.
Elle pénètre,
donc cette espérance,
elle pénètre au-delà du voile,
là où Jésus
est entré pour nous
comme précurseur,
ayant été fait
souverain sacrificateur
pour toujours
selon l'ordre
de Melchisedec.
Nous sommes assurés
de notre triomphe
par l'entrée
de notre grand prêtre.
Et la question
donc à laquelle
nous ayons essayé
de répondre,
c'est en quoi
l'entrée de Christ
dans le lieu saint,
en quoi l'entrée de Christ
par-delà le voile
assure le triomphe
du chrétien,
assure,
vous assure
de votre espérance éternelle.
En fait,
dans l'Épître aux Hébreux,
nous sommes devant le cours,
peut-être le cours
le plus magistral
de théologie biblique.
Nous sommes devant
un enseignant,
certainement l'apôtre Paul,
qui est en train
de dévoiler
tout le lien
et tout le processus,
la continuité
de l'Ancien Testament,
les ombres,
les types
vers Jésus-Christ,
l'aboutissement
de toutes ces ombres.
On est devant
un cours
qui est magistral.
Et nous avons besoin,
nous aussi,
quand on lit,
surtout verset par verset,
de nous rappeler
de cette dynamique
de l'auteur aux Hébreux,
de cette théologie biblique
où il est en train
de déployer
les thèmes
propres à l'Ancien Testament
et voir comment
elles s'accomplissent
en Jésus-Christ
dans le développement
historique
et le développement
théologique.
Christ a traversé
le voile.
De quel voile
il parle ?
Du temple.
De quel temple
il parle ?
Qu'est-ce que le temple ?
Et en quoi la traversée
de ce voile
assure le triomphe
du chrétien ?
Eh bien, nous aussi,
nous allons faire
un peu de théologie biblique
dans ce premier point
en nous rappelant
pour bien profiter
de la signification
de cette entrée
de nos grands prêtres
pour le peuple de Dieu.
Le temple en essence,
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
c'est l'endroit
que Dieu a choisi
pour se manifester
particulièrement
dans son être,
exposer
plus ou moins directement,
plus ou moins partiellement
l'expression
de son être.
Et ce temple
avait une vocation,
surtout après la chute,
de communier gracieusement
avec le joyau
de sa création,
l'homme déchu.
Certains pourraient dire
« Oui, mais Dieu est
omniprésent. »
Pourquoi a-t-il fait le temple ?
Puisque de toute façon,
Dieu est partout.
Il est esprit.
Et la réalité
qu'on peut observer,
c'est que même
les inconvertis
peuvent jouir
de la présence de Dieu
puisque Dieu est partout.
Et c'est vrai
dans un certain sens.
Dieu est à l'Église,
Dieu est aux confins
du monde,
Dieu est au paradis,
Dieu est présent
en enfer,
Dieu est présent partout,
Dieu est esprit.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que
dans cette omniprésence
de Dieu,
Dieu a choisi
de ne pas exposer
pleinement l'expression
de son être
à sa créature.
Dieu se manifeste
comme de façon
voilée,
restreinte
dans ses œuvres
et dans ses actions
pour que ses créatures
puissent le supporter.
Et si Dieu dévoilait
pleinement
l'expression
de son être
ne serait-ce qu'un instant,
nous serions tous
irradiés
par ces rayons foudroyants.
L'homme n'aurait pas
la capacité,
d'autant plus
l'homme déchu,
la création déchue
n'aurait pas
la capacité
de tenir
dans l'expression
le dévoilement
de l'être de Dieu.
Vous voyez
quand on présente
l'homme
comme un ennemi de Dieu
en réalité
la relation de Dieu
et l'homme
est même plus facile
à comprendre que ça.
Si Dieu ne faisait
que dévoiler
qui il était réellement
dans l'étendue
et l'infini
de sa gloire,
ça ne serait fini
pour l'homme.
Le Dieu de la Bible
ne peut
ni être vu
ni approché
naturellement.
Et personne
ne peut dire
moi je suis en intimité
naturellement avec Dieu.
Personne ne peut être
en intimité
avec quelque chose
qui le détruit,
qui le consomme.
personne naturellement
ne peut être
en intimité
avec ce Dieu.
Ce n'est pas un Dieu
qui est amadouable
par des régimes alimentaires,
par des restrictions,
par des habitudes de vie.
Le Dieu biblique
ne peut être
ni vu
ni approché.
D'autant plus
par sa création déchue.
Mais par la présence
du temple,
Dieu est en train
de manifester
quelque chose.
il est en train
de manifester
à cette création déchue
et en particulier
avec la créature
avec qui il veut
communier particulièrement,
l'homme,
qu'il a un désir
de communier avec lui.
Que malgré
cette distance infinie
qui nous sépare,
il réserve
un endroit
où il se manifestera
d'une façon particulière
avec lui
sous des conditions
très précises.
Et voilà
le but du temple.
et le temple
est donc
un
constant rappel
de la
disposition de Dieu
de communier
avec nous,
mais c'est aussi
un puissant rappel
de l'infinité
qui nous sépare
de Dieu.
Et si vous lisez
l'Ancien Testament,
si vous lisez
même les Lévitiques,
ne soyez pas perdus
dans tous les techniques,
tous les langages,
etc.,
mais concentrez-vous
sur ce que Dieu
veut ultimement
communiquer.
l'homme ne peut pas
communier
naturellement
avec Dieu.
Mais Dieu
a une volonté
et une intention
de communier
avec lui.
Et nous allons
revenir rapidement
à cette compréhension
du temple
dans la Bible.
Le temple,
évidemment,
a été déjà présenté
au Jardin d'Éden
d'une façon
typifiée,
dans une ombre.
Dieu communiait
avec l'humanité
avant la chute.
Adam et Ève
servaient comme
des prêtres
avant l'heure
où ils étaient
chargés de veiller,
de garder le jardin
dans cette communion
avec Dieu.
Mais c'est surtout
après la chute
que nous voyons
le caractère
gracieux du temple
et la disposition
de Dieu
de vouloir communier
avec l'homme.
Vous vous rappelez
sur le Mont Sinaï ?
Sur le Mont Sinaï,
nous avons déjà
une représentation
encore plus vibrante
du temple.
Vous vous rappelez,
le peuple était
en contrebas,
la première partie.
Le peuple d'Israël
n'avait pas le droit
de s'approcher
de cette montagne.
Si quelqu'un
se disait
« Moi, je vais communier
avec Dieu »,
Dieu se présente
sur cette montagne
et touchait cette montagne,
il devait être puni,
frappé de mort
par le peuple.
Si même un animal,
aussi innocent soit-il,
s'approcherait-il
de la montagne,
il devait être puni
de mort.
Le peuple
en contrebas.
Puis nous avons
les anciens
à Aaron
qui pouvaient s'approcher
sur le flanc
de la montagne
et accompagner Moïse.
c'était les prêtres
avant l'heure.
Mais ils ne pouvaient
pas aller plus loin.
Ils s'approchaient
de la présence
manifestée
d'une façon particulière
en haut de cette montagne,
mais ils devaient
rester sur le flanc
de la montagne.
Et là-haut,
dans cette nuée
terrifiante,
assourdissante
par les éclairs,
par le tonnerre,
là où Dieu a choisi
de se manifester
partiellement,
un seul homme
pouvait rentrer.
Dans cette nuée
ténébreuse
qui était un voile
avant l'heure,
un seul homme
pouvait s'approcher
et demeurer
dans la présence
partielle,
dans l'expression
partielle
de l'être de Dieu.
Et Moïse
a été élu
pour être cet homme.
Et c'est la raison
pour laquelle
lorsque Moïse
plus tard
a introduit
la notion du temple,
eh bien,
la compréhension
du peuple d'Israël
au sujet du temple
était déjà
présente quelque part.
Le peuple
pouvait s'avancer
comme ils l'ont fait
devant le monde Sinaï
dans la cour du temple,
dans l'éparvis du temple
pour apporter
leurs offrandes
et leurs hommages.
Mais aucun
membre
de la tribu d'Israël,
même s'il était animé
de bonnes
dispositions,
de bonnes intentions,
aucun membre
du peuple d'Israël
n'avait le droit
de rentrer
et de franchir
les rideaux
du temple.
Même un illustre
membre de la tribu
de Juda
n'avait pas le droit
de dire
« bon,
moi,
je vais adorer mon Dieu
plus proche
et je vais rentrer
dans ce temple. »
Sanction immédiate,
foudroyée
par la sainteté
de Dieu.
Seule une tribu
pouvait y rentrer,
la tribu de Lévi
qui a manifesté
son zèle
pour la conservation
de la sainteté
de Dieu.
Seule une tribu
pouvait y rentrer
mais sous
certaines conditions.
seulement pour exécuter
les tâches
que Dieu
l'avait ordonnées
de faire.
Pas plus,
certains ont essayé
plus
et ont été
foudroyés
par la colère
de Dieu
immédiatement,
pas moins.
Seulement
sous certaines conditions.
Et dans ce temple
où les prêtres
pouvaient rentrer,
il y avait
un lieu interdit,
un lieu protégé,
un lieu secret.
au confin du temple
se tenait
un lieu
qui était
couvert
par,
quand on lit
les Écritures,
à peu près
200 mètres carrés
de tapis
qui était le voile.
10 centimètres
d'épaisseur,
20 mètres
de longueur,
10 mètres
de largeur.
Un lieu imposant,
un lieu
qui marquait
la séparation
du peuple d'Israël
avec Dieu
à l'intérieur.
mais un lieu
qui marquait
l'intention de Dieu
de vouloir communier
avec eux.
Un lieu
interdit
et celui
qui s'approchait
s'approchait
d'un feu foudroyant.
Personne
ne pouvait
franchir
ce rideau
avec
la confiance
d'en ressortir
vivant.
C'était
le lieu
très saint,
séparé
par le voile
que Dieu
avait ordonné
de mettre
à son peuple.
Ce voile
agissait
comme une protection
pour protéger
le peuple d'Israël
de l'exposition
de la gloire
de Dieu.
Et ce voile
agissait
comme un rappel
symbolique
que vous êtes
privés
de la gloire
de Dieu.
L'homme
est privé
de la gloire
de Dieu.
Un lieu
inaccessible.
Vous ne pouvez
pas entrer
dans ma présence
même si ce n'est
que l'expression
partielle
de ma gloire.
Voilà le lieu
très saint.
et ce que
Moïse a vu
sur le mont Sinaï
et ça c'est
vraiment un argumentaire
un point d'argument
très fort
dans le chapitre 8
que l'auteur
utilisera par la suite
on y reviendra.
Mais ce que
Moïse a vu
sur le mont Sinaï
sur le haut
de cette montagne
l'auteur va nous dire
va nous rappeler
c'est pas qu'il va
nous enseigner
c'est qu'il va nous rappeler
l'expérience
de Moïse
sur cette montagne.
Sur cette montagne
Moïse
a donné
les instructions
ou a écrit
relatifs au temple
terrestre
basé sur le modèle
qu'il a vu.
Autrement dit
l'auteur
est en train
de nous dire
ce que Moïse
a vu
sur cette montagne
ce n'est pas tant
la vision
que Dieu lui a donnée
n'est pas tant
le temple terrestre
Moïse a eu
un aperçu
dans quelle mesure
je ne sais pas
mais Moïse
a eu lui-même
un aperçu
du véritable temple
le temple
céleste
un temple
qui n'est pas
fait de main d'homme
un temple
qui quelque part
n'est pas
de la même nature
que le temple
qu'il va être amené
à construire
et à donner
des instructions
et donc
il était clair
pour le peuple
d'Israël
et même
pour Moïse
il était clair
que le temple
terrestre
n'était pas
du tout
une fin en soi
mais le temple
terrestre
a toujours
été donné
au peuple
d'Israël
pour rappeler
des réalités
célestes
au sujet
de la présence
immédiate
de Dieu
dans l'expression
pleine
de sa gloire
et de sa sainteté
non pas restreinte
comme c'est le cas
dans le temple
mais il y a un lieu
céleste
où Dieu se manifeste
dans la plénitude
de sa gloire
de sa sainteté
une plénitude
qui nous est encore
inaccessible
elle nous est déjà
dans le temple
terrestre
elle nous l'est
à d'autant plus
raison
dans l'expression
pleine de la gloire
et de la sainteté
de Dieu
un lieu secret
un lieu inaccessible
pour l'homme
et quand je lisais
Luc
dernièrement
j'ai été arrêté
sur un détail
qui
qui m'a
qui m'a beaucoup
encouragé
au Luc
chapitre 9
Luc nous rappelle
cet événement
de la transfiguration
où devant
certains disciples
l'apparence
de Jésus Christ
s'est transformée
et Jésus
s'est trouvé
en train de discuter
avec Élie
et Moïse
vous connaissez
cet événement
qui nous est rapporté
par plusieurs évangélistes
mais Luc
va rajouter un détail
et dans cette discussion
Moïse
le représentant
de la loi
la loi
qui aboutit
en Christ
et Moïse
voit l'accomplissement
de la loi
en Jésus Christ
face à lui
Élie
le représentant
de tous les prophètes
tous les prophéties
convergées
vers Christ
ultimement
et Élie
se tient
devant l'antitype
Jésus Christ
et dans cette conversation
au-dessus du temps
et bien Luc
va nous dire
quel était le sujet
de leur discussion
et Luc
va nous dire
qu'ils se sont
entretenus
au sujet
du départ
de Jésus Christ
qu'il allait faire
à partir de Jérusalem
autrement dit
Jésus était en train
de discuter
avec Moïse
et Élie
au sujet
de son ascension
dans la gloire
de sa mort
de sa résurrection
et de l'entrée
dans la présence
immédiate
de la gloire de Dieu
imaginez-vous Moïse
lui qui a vu
sur le mont Sinaï
une partie
de ce temple céleste
lui qui a accédé
dans ce lieu
très saint
de l'époque
et qui a vu
un lieu
encore plus inaccessible
encore plus interdit
pour la race déchue humaine
et voici Jésus
qui se tient devant lui
et qui lui dit
je rentrerai
dans la présence
immédiate de Dieu
ce que tu as vu
Moïse
sur cette montagne
j'y rentrerai
un jour
et j'y rentrerai
avec triomphe
ce qui était interdit
pour le temple terrestre
j'y rentrerai
avec audace
je serai
devant la face
immédiate
de Dieu
Moïse
là où
règne
la tranquillité
la paisibilité
pour celui
qui est parfait
comme Dieu lui-même
un lieu
qui était
autrefois
interdit
et vous vous rappelez
dans ce jardin
d'Éden
lorsqu'ils ont chuté
qu'ils nous étaient
expulsés
de cette présence
de Dieu
de la gloire
Adam et Ève
qu'est-ce que Dieu a mis
Dieu a mis des chérubins
pour interdire aux hommes
de rentrer dans la présence
de Dieu
avec des épées
à leurs mains
pour que le message
soit encore plus clair
mais Jésus
devant cette présence
immédiate
et pleine
de la gloire de Dieu
malgré la présence
des chérubins
qui défendent
avec ferveur
la sainteté de Dieu
les anges ont vu
un homme s'approcher
le fils de l'homme
lui-même
les hommes ont vu
cet homme
que Dieu le Père
avait frappé
sur ce bois
s'approcher d'eux
et pénétrer le voile
et rentrer devant
la face
de Dieu le Père
ce qui nous était
autrefois interdit
dangereusement
comme nous l'avons vu
dans cette introduction
Daniel 7
nous parle
du couronnement
de Christ
lorsqu'il entre
dans la gloire
c'est pas une entrée
à pas feutrer
comme les souverains
sacrificateurs
pouvaient le faire
dans le lait très saint
on peut imaginer
la crainte
des souverains
sacrificateurs
le jour qui arrive
le yom kippour
qui arrive
quelle crainte
quel tremblement
mais Christ n'entre pas
à pas feutrer
dans la présence
immédiate de Dieu
il entre avec triomphe
il sait qu'il va y être
chaleureusement
accueilli
et là
dans son couronnement
céleste
là où toutes
les couronnes
de ce monde
seront déposées
là où seul Christ
pourra s'avancer
les genoux vont ploire
devant lui
tout être humain
sera
à genoux
converti
inconverti
tout le monde
sera à genoux
devant l'entrée
triomphante de Christ
dans l'ascension
Abel
verra
son sauveur
Abraham
a vu
la promesse
rentrer
dans la présence
de Dieu
nos pères
qui nous ont précédés
dans la foi
nos pères biologiques
ou nos pères
dans la foi
qui sont déjà
dans la gloire
et qui ont vu
Christ entrer
dans le couronnement
avec triomphe
avec éclat
Adam lui-même
a vu
son second Adam
son antitype
rentrer
et renverser
la malédiction
qu'il avait apportée
sur la terre
l'entrée
triomphante
de Christ
non pas
dans un lieu
terrestre
saint terrestre
ni dans un lieu
très saint terrestre
mais devant la face
immédiate
devant le visage
de Dieu le Père
que même
les anges
eux-mêmes
qui n'ont pas chuté
ne peuvent même pas regarder
ayant les ailes
sur leurs yeux
Christ
devant le visage
du Père
oui autrefois
cette présence
nous était privée
interdite
Christ
y est entré
avec audace
l'entrée
de Jésus-Christ
nous assure
le triomphe éternel
mais cette entrée
bien que c'était
l'oeuvre
exclusive
de Jésus
n'est pas une démarche
exclusive
ce n'était pas
simplement
pour son propre
plaisir personnel
et c'est notre
deuxième point
la disposition
de notre grand prêtre
nous assure
le triomphe
Jésus est entré
mais Jésus est entré
pour nous
verset 20
là où est Jésus
là où Jésus
est entré
pour nous
quelque part
ces trois mots
Jésus pour nous
sont les plus glorieux
de toute la Bible
ce sont les mots
les plus doux
que nos âmes
peuvent entendre
et quand je préparais
ce serment
j'ai dû
même tard
effacer
toutes les
enfin toutes
je n'ai pas pensé
à toutes
mais
nous allons nous arrêter
seulement sur certains aspects
dans lesquels
Christ est entré
pour nous
en tant que prêtre
et comment
l'entrée de Christ
en notre faveur
pour nous
nous assure
de notre triomphe
premièrement
Christ est entré
pour nous
en tant que
notre représentant
et c'est l'office
c'est le rôle
le plus évident
de Christ
dans ce passage
Christ en tant que prêtre
va rentrer
pour son peuple
Adam et Ève
étaient dans un cadre
d'alliance
dans le jardin d'Éden
dans un cadre
de communion
avec Dieu
qu'il avait contracté
seulement avec la race humaine
et Adam et Ève
étaient des représentants
de la race humaine
c'est à dire
que tout ce que
Adam et Ève
faisaient
nous le faisions
en leur nom
ou ils le faisaient
en notre nom
à tous
plutôt
nous étions
comme quelque part
si je peux emprunter
le langage
néo-testamentaire
nous étions quelque part
cachés en Adam et Ève
ils étaient nos représentants
et s'ils obéissaient
ils auraient acquis
les bénédictions
en notre nom
s'ils ont désobéi
ils ont attiré
la malédiction
sur l'humanité
tout entière
et aucun secours
ne pouvait venir
ni des anges
qui n'étaient pas
dans le cadre
de cette alliance
des œuvres
avec l'homme et Dieu
ni des animaux
il n'y avait
aucun secours
et le temple
est cette lueur
d'espoir
que Dieu présente
je désire communier
avec cette race déchue
je vous ai chassé
du jardin
mais je veux élire
un peuple
pour qu'il puisse
communier
avec moi
et comme Adam et Ève
ont été vos représentants
dans ce temple
je veux qu'un homme
soit le représentant
de tout le peuple
et s'avance une fois par an
dans le lieu très simple
le Yom Kippour
le jour d'expiation
pour représenter
tout le peuple
quel donc
quel est cet homme
qui aurait la capacité
de se présenter
dans le lieu très saint
de Dieu
absolument
certain
ça devait être
un homme unique
exceptionnel
quel pourrait être
cet homme
qui pourrait représenter
l'humanité tout entière
est-ce que c'est Moïse
celui
de qui il est dit
et aucun autre homme
dans l'Ancien Testament
on ne dit ça de lui
qu'il est l'ami de Dieu
une intimité avec Dieu
est-ce que Moïse
est cet homme
qui pourra nous représenter
lui qui était
de nombreuses fois
le médiateur
entre Dieu et le peuple
mais Moïse était
de la même nature que nous
sali par la corruption
du péché
comment penser
que quelqu'un
qui n'a même pas pu
rentrer à Canaan
pourrait rentrer
devant la face
immédiate
de la gloire de Dieu
en notre nom
à tous
il ne fallait pas
simplement un homme
pour nous représenter
mais il fallait
un homme parfait
et même
mes frères et sœurs
même un homme parfait
ne suffirait pas
si un homme
avait échappé
à la corruption naturelle
là je pars dans
quelque chose d'hypothétique
car nous savons que c'est impossible
mais quand bien même
il y aurait eu un homme
qui avait échappé
à sa condition naturelle
de pécheur
issue d'Adam et Ève
quand bien même
il y aurait eu un homme
qui avait vécu une vie
sans péché
à chaque seconde
micro seconde
de sa vie
aimant Dieu
de tout son cœur
de toute son âme
de toute sa pensée
accomplissant la loi de Dieu
quand bien même
un tel homme
existerait
et quand bien même
cet homme
pourrait même
se présenter
dans la présence de Dieu
à cause de sa sainteté
il ne pourrait pas
être notre représentant
il se représenterait
lui-même
sa perfection
circonscrite
à lui-même
ne suffirait pas
pour représenter
l'humanité perdue
pour que nous ayons
un représentant
qui représente
des pécheurs
il faut que sa sainteté
inonde l'univers
il faut que sa perfection
comble à satiété
toutes les exigences
de Dieu
non seulement
il faut que ce soit
un homme
mais il faut que cet homme
soit parfait
soit Dieu lui-même
parce que seul Dieu
comble à satiété
ses propres exigences
et c'est là
où les chrétiens
doivent être assurés
de la nécessité
de la nature divine
de notre médiateur
entrer pour nous
notre représentant
Jésus
conçu par le Saint-Esprit
en Marie
vraiment homme
vraiment Dieu
est capable
de nous représenter
et lorsqu'il retourne
dans l'association
il ne va pas simplement
retourner
voir son père
il vient pour
représenter
le peuple
de Dieu
pour combler
à satiété
les exigences
divines de Dieu
en faveur
de son peuple
pour restaurer
éternellement
une race déchue
qui a perdu
la présence de Dieu
notre filiation
adamique
pour les chrétiens
est derrière nous
Dieu
lorsqu'il nous regarde
il ne voit plus
un membre
de la race
d'Adam
quelque part
Dieu
lorsqu'il nous décrit
il ne voit plus
nos transgressions
vos erreurs passées
il ne nous décrit plus
selon le filtre
d'Adam
si vous avez mis
votre foi réellement
en Christ
lorsque Dieu
vous regarde
il voit votre représentant
Jésus Christ
lui-même
dont la perfection
est infinie
dont l'obéissance
est parfaite
voilà comment Christ
vous regarde
chrétien
parfait
pur
comblant
à satiété
les exigences de Dieu
à cause de votre
représentant
les implications
sont énormes
pour notre vie pratique
nous qui
pouvons nous accuser
nous qui pouvons
entendre la douce voix
de l'accusateur
contre nous
mais Dieu ne vous voit
plus à travers Adam
il vous voit
au travers Jésus Christ
oui nous sommes appelés
à faire un examen
continuel
de nous
oui nous sommes appelés
à percevoir
les signes de vie
de Christ
en nous
et c'est un appel
constant dans les
saintes écritures
mais la vie
chrétienne
ne peut pas être
résumée
à un examen
morbide
de nous-mêmes
en essayant de trouver
en nous-mêmes
de l'assurance
pour plaire Dieu
le Seigneur
veut nous rappeler
et si c'est le cas
vous avez raison
d'être anxieux
si c'était le cas
vous aviez raison
d'être plein de craintes
si le Seigneur
attend que vous
vous trouvez
votre réconfort
en examinant
votre vie
vos pensées
continuellement
vous avez raison
d'être des gens vacillants
la réalité
c'est que vous avez
un représentant
la réalité
c'est que vous avez
quelqu'un
qui se tient déjà
devant la face du Père
et qui vous représente
déjà
ton nom
devant la face du Père
oui
Christ est entré
pour nous
en tant que notre
représentant
et il est rentré
aussi pour nous
dans le sens
qu'il avait
des bonnes dispositions
envers nous
Dieu étant
Jésus Christ
notre souverain
sacrificateur
est en notre
faveur
les prêtres
auraient dû
déjà manifester ça
envers le peuple
d'Israël
les prêtres
auraient dû
déjà
être l'image
du caractère
de Christ
en tant que
le véritable prêtre
et ils auraient dû
manifester
cet élan
de compassion
en voyant
ces misérables
s'approcher de lui
marqués par les mêmes
péchés
en voyant
ces personnes
trompées
séduites
par le malin
et bien
ces prêtres
auraient dû
manifester
de la compassion
envers le peuple
de Dieu
mais pourtant
la Bible
l'Ancien Testament
décrit
et même le nouveau
d'ailleurs
décrit souvent
les prêtres
du temple terrestre
plutôt comme
des maîtres
tyranniques
que comme
des gens
remplis de compassion
et d'hébergers
pour le peuple
de Dieu
et imaginez-vous
faire partie
du peuple
d'Israël
devant
le juge
suprême
qui est Dieu
devant
ce tribunal
où vous
vous savez
coupable
devant la loi
sainte de Dieu
et imaginez-vous
avoir des avocats
des représentants
qui n'ont
aucun souci
pour vous
aucune compassion
et qui sont
chargés
de vous représenter
vous coupable
devant le Dieu
très saint
voilà la situation
pleine d'angoisse
pleine de crainte
mais le chrétien
vit une réalité
complètement différente
et
Ézéchiel 34
nous décrit
de façon détaillée
quelle était
la manifestation
du manque
de compassion
de ceux qui
auraient dû être
les pasteurs
d'Israël
Ézéchiel
chapitre 34
au lieu
de la compassion
et bien
il nous montre
que les pasteurs
d'Israël
étaient pleins
d'égoïsme
malheur
aux pasteurs
d'Israël
qui se paissent
eux-mêmes
autrement dit
ils n'ont
aucun souci
de la nourriture
spirituelle du peuple
eux les prêtres
tout ce qui leur importe
c'est d'être nourri
c'est d'être honoré
au lieu de la compassion
de l'indifférence
Ézéchiel 34
vous n'avez pas fortifié
les brebis
qui étaient faibles
et ces choses-là
n'ont pas changé
même quand Jésus
était là
on voit
dans le temple
et dans la cour du temple
au temps de Jésus
des personnes
qui se faisaient manipuler
on leur vendait des choses
en prétextant
que plus ils allaient acheter
plus ils allaient être
favorables devant Dieu
même les pauvres
les plus manipulables
des choses qui sont
qui résonnent encore
dans l'histoire de l'église
encore aujourd'hui
et tout cela
sous le regard des prêtres
qui auraient dû avoir
de compassion
pour les pauvres
et les affligés
au lieu de la compassion
du mépris
Ézéchiel 34
vous les avez dominés
avec violence
et avec dureté
et ils ont vu
leur titre
que Dieu leur avait conféré
pour être les médiateurs
entre Dieu et l'homme
ils ont pris ce titre
comme étant quelque chose
dont ils pouvaient se glorifier
je suis supérieur au peuple
et au lieu de voir
des brebis
que je devrais chérir
je vois des proies
à dévorer
dont je peux extraire
de l'argent
de la gloire
dont je peux extraire
de la réputation
égoïsme
indifférence
mépris
qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait attendre
de tels avocats
devant la sainte présence de Dieu
qu'est-ce que le peuple d'Israël
pouvait attendre
de tels avocats
mais notre avocat
celui qui vient
en tant que souverain sacrificateur
a des dispositions
envers nous
complètement différentes
il est décrit
comme étant notre bon berger
celui qui prend soin
des âmes
de son peuple
et il vient nous défendre
en notre faveur
devant la face de Dieu
il ne vient pas
en son propre nom
devant la face de Dieu
il vient pour défendre
ce qu'il aime
et il ne vient pas
nous défendre
en essayant
d'enlever notre culpabilité
en cherchant en nous
des circonstances atténuantes
comme pourrait le faire
un avocat
non
il vient en assumant
notre faute
ta misère
et il vient en étendant
ses mains
et en montrant
comment il a tout pris
sur sa propre chair
comment l'éternité
en enfer
qui nous était réservée
a été satisfaite
en lui
et comment ses mains
sont remplies
de fruits de justice
qui comblent la satiété
et les exigences de Dieu
voilà comment notre avocat
se présente
en notre faveur
Dieu
en Jésus Christ
particulièrement
dans son ministère terrestre
à combien de reprises
a-t-il manifesté
son amour
pour le pécheur
à combien de reprises
il est dit
dans les écritures
qu'il regardait la foule
perdue
et qu'il était ému
de compassion
Dieu
veut vous assurer
chrétien
que vous êtes aimé
d'un vrai amour
et que vous avez
un avocat
qui vous représente
et qui défend
votre cause
mais qui vous aime
réellement
un vrai amour
un amour
qui n'a pas eu peur
de montrer notre misère
un amour
qui n'a pas eu peur
de nous condamner
un amour
qui n'a pas eu peur
de montrer
combien nous méritions
la colère de Dieu
personne ne m'a aimé
comme Christ m'a aimé
personne ne t'a aimé
comme Christ t'aime
chrétien
un amour
qu'il a manifesté
pour celui
qui est plein de désespoir
celui qui est abandonné
et voilà l'état de l'homme
abandonné
désespoir
aucune aide
tout ce qu'il pourrait faire
même s'il pense
les faire pour Dieu
ne viendrait qu'aggraver sa cause
parce qu'en pensant
pouvoir apporter des choses
à Dieu
il insulte la sainteté
de Dieu lui-même
pensant que Dieu
pourrait être amadoué
par ce qu'un homme
corrompu
pourrait produire
Dieu est venu
à notre secours
et le même
Ézéchiel
qui a décrit
la violence des bergers
et bien le même
Ézéchiel
va aussi décrire
l'amour
du vrai berger
envers le peuple d'Israël
un amour
envers celui
qui n'a aucun espoir
qui gît dans son sang
Ézéchiel
au chapitre 16
je vais vous lire
ces passages
si poétiques
et que nous pourrions
chacun d'entre nous
nous appliquer
à ta naissance
au jour
où tu naquis
ton nombril
n'a pas été coupé
tu n'as pas été
lavé dans l'eau
pour être purifié
nul n'a porté sur toi
un regard de pitié
pour te faire
une seule de ces choses
par compassion
pour toi
mais tu as été
jeté dans les champs
le jour de ta naissance
parce qu'on avait
horreur de toi
ne vous trompez pas
voilà une description
de l'homme
naturel
sans espoir
sale
misérable
mais je passais
près de toi
je t'aperçus
baigné dans ton sang
et je te dis
vis
dans ton sang
j'étendis sur toi
le pan de ma robe
je couvris ta nudité
je te jurais fidélité
je fis alliance
avec toi
dit le Seigneur
et tu fus à moi
voilà l'amour
que Jésus nous porte
devant la face de Dieu
voilà l'expression
de l'amour
la disposition
du bon berger
qu'il a
maintenant
qu'il a traversé
le voile
il est dit
du souverain
sacrificateur
qu'il a les noms
du peuple de Dieu
sur son torse
Dieu
Jésus Christ
devant la face de Dieu
a ton nom précisément
sur son coeur
pour manifester
que continuellement
et pour l'éternité
tu es l'objet
de l'amour
de Jésus Christ
devant la face de Dieu
tu n'as aucune crainte
à avoir
ton avocat t'aime
ton avocat
te défend
avec ferveur
Jésus Christ
est entré
pour nous
en tant que représentant
avec des bonnes dispositions
et pour notre bien
c'est à dire que
quel bien nous serait-il
que quelqu'un nous représente
que quelqu'un nous aime
s'il nous offre
quelque chose
qui au final
n'est pas ce qu'on désire
réellement
mais lorsque Jésus
est entré
il est entré
pour nous
pour notre bien
ultime
pour notre joie
pour la pleine satisfaction
de notre âme
et je ne pourrais même pas
décrire ce qui nous attend
après la mort
les mots que je pourrais dire
seraient incohérents
mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que les plus grands
plaisirs de notre vie
les moments les plus intenses
d'expérience de joie
de paix
de quiétude
que vous avez pu vivre
ne sont
que pâle
devant les moments
que nous allons passer
sans pause
sans répit
sans lassitude
devant la face
de notre Dieu
devant Jésus Christ
qui est non seulement
la source de tout bien
mais qui est lui-même
le bien
ultime
suprême
pour notre bien
c'est notre paradis
notre paradis sera
consistera
à contempler
cet océan de gloire
qu'est Jésus Christ
sans pause
sans lassitude
et il est rentré
pour nous
non seulement
pour notre bien
mais il est vraiment
rentré pour nous
et
comment dirais-je
je dirais que pour nous
Jésus pour nous
c'est même ce qui
distingue le christianisme
de toutes les autres religions
Dieu pour nous
c'est l'essence même
du christianisme
aucune autre religion
même les formes
de christianisme
corrompues
aucune autre religion
ne présente un Dieu
pour nous
il présente
il présente peut-être
un Dieu
qui s'abaisse à nous
et qui peut
manifester une certaine
forme de miséricorde
envers l'homme
mais il présente
que des dieux
qui attendent
que l'homme
ultimement
fasse le pas vers lui
ou que l'homme
agisse en répondant
par des oeuvres
et une fois que l'homme
aura travaillé
il recevra le salaire
la vie éternelle
ou 72 vierges
ou que sais-je encore
mais le Dieu
de l'évangile
est un Dieu
pour nous
c'est un Dieu
qui comble
l'infinitude
qui nous sépare
de sa création
une infinitude
qui ne pourrait pas
être comblée
par vos oeuvres
par vos pèlerinages
par de l'encens
que vous allumez
Dieu n'est pas
un Dieu stupide
un Dieu amadouable
Dieu est un Dieu saint
Dieu est un Dieu
infiniment saint
ce n'est pas parce que
vous ne mangez pas de porc
que vous arriverez au paradis
ce n'est pas parce que
vous faites ceci
ou telle oeuvre
que vous pourrez amadouer
la très sainte sainteté
de Dieu
et devant cette impossibilité
pour nous
de nous réjouir de Dieu
Dieu est venu
pour nous
et il a pourvu
à ses propres exigences
il est descendu
et accompli
ce que nous n'aurions
pas pu accomplir
voilà le centre
de l'évangile
Dieu
Jésus
pour nous
Dieu
Dieu qui accomplit
ce que nous n'aurions
jamais pu accomplir
voilà pourquoi
l'auteur nous rappelle
ces choses
afin que par l'entrée
de Christ
en tant que souverain
sacrificateur
nous puissions être
assurés de notre triomphe
ce lieu autrefois interdit
afin que par la disposition
de notre grand prêtre
nous puissions être assurés
de notre triomphe
et enfin pour conclure
nous sommes assurés
de notre triomphe
par le rôle de précurseur
de Jésus Christ
lisons à nouveau
le verset 20
là où Jésus
est entré
pour nous
comme précurseur
c'est la seule fois
dans la parole de Dieu
que le mot précurseur
est attaché
à Jésus Christ
mais cette seule fois
suffit pour qu'on puisse
s'arrêter
méditer
et être émerveillé
par ces nouveaux détails
au sujet
du ministère de Christ
donc on doit comprendre
qu'est-ce que l'auteur
a en esprit
lorsqu'il utilise
cette
je ne sais pas
si je devrais appeler ça
office
mais ce statut
de précurseur
et lorsqu'il l'associe
à Jésus Christ
lui-même
qu'est-ce que l'auteur
dans son contexte historique
avait en tête
pour parler de précurseur
d'un point de vue étymologique
précurseur
c'est un avant-coureur
c'est quelqu'un
qui court vite
qui doit courir
avant l'arrivée
d'une personne importante
généralement des rois
et sa fonction
elle est double
à ce précurseur
non seulement
il doit courir avant
pour apporter
le message du roi
en avance
pour influencer
une place publique
les personnes
que le roi
va finalement rencontrer
mais de façon pratique
il doit aussi
préparer
l'arrivée du roi
préparer l'arrivée
d'une personne
supérieure à lui
il doit déblayer
la route
si besoin
il doit voir
s'il y a des embuscades
il doit préparer
l'accueil
pour l'arrivée
du roi
c'est pas du tout
un titre honorifique
précurseur
c'est un titre servile
c'est quelqu'un
qui s'avance
pour
en tant que messager
de quelqu'un de supérieur
c'est quelqu'un
qui va faire face
aux premières réactions
après avoir déclaré
le message
du roi
première réaction
vive
parfois de la foule
c'est celui
qui va s'exposer
dans un rôle solitaire
aux embuscades
et le premier exemple
biblique
et le plus significatif
peut-être pas le premier
mais le plus significatif
en tant que précurseur
c'est Jean-Baptiste
Jean-Baptiste
est présenté
par le prophète
Malachie
donc qui a annoncé
la venue de Jean-Baptiste
comme un précurseur
qui arrivera
avant l'arrivée du Messie
un homme qui va arriver
annoncer la venue
de quelqu'un de supérieur
un homme qui va arriver
annoncer le message
du roi qui va venir
et Jean-Baptiste
était cet homme
un homme qui va préparer
l'arrivée du royaume de Dieu
qui va commencer
à prêcher la repentance
et un homme
qui sait son statut servile
un homme qui
lorsqu'il va voir
Jésus-Christ
s'approcher de lui
va s'agenouiller à terre
et va dire
voilà mon roi
voici l'agneau de Dieu
je ne suis même pas digne
de délier ses souliers
voilà le rôle de précurseur
un rôle de préparation
et Jean-Baptiste
n'a pas échappé non plus
à l'animosité
que rencontrait souvent
le rôle solitaire
du précurseur
puisqu'il a lui-même
fini sa vie
étant décapité
sans richesse
solitaire
annonçant
la venue
d'un roi
mais ici
ce rôle de précurseur
est prêté à Jésus-Christ
lui-même
et lorsqu'on s'y arrête
et qu'on pense à Jésus
en tant que précurseur
et que le rôle de précurseur
c'est quelqu'un
qui annonce
l'arrivée d'un roi
on pourrait penser
que le rôle de précurseur
de Jésus
est lié à sa première venue
quelque part
intuitivement
que Jésus est venu
annoncer
l'arrivée du grand roi
du grand retour
et il est venu
en tant que précurseur
dans une tâche servile
mais ici
ce n'est pas ce que l'auteur
est en train de nous dire
il prête ce rôle
de précurseur
à l'ascension
de Christ
dans la gloire
pour la première fois
de l'histoire
mes frères et sœurs
c'est le roi
qui annonce
l'arrivée
de ces sujets
pour la première fois
de l'histoire
c'est ce roi
serviteur
glorieux
qui entre
dans la présence
de Dieu
et qui annonce
l'arrivée
des serviteurs
et des esclaves
que nous sommes
le roi serviteur
ultime
le précurseur
servile
ce roi
qui s'est abaissé
jusqu'à laver
nos propres pieds
est arrivé
devant la face
de Dieu
et a annoncé
notre arrivée
vous voyez
nous avons tellement
peut-être
à raison
je dirais
nous prenons garde
à toute forme
d'évangile
qui met la lumière
sur l'homme
qui est centré
mais nous ne devons
pas oublier
à quelle hauteur
Dieu lui-même
nous a élevés
il annonce
notre arrivée
devant la face
de Dieu le Père
il annonce
l'arrivée
de ces enfants
bien-aimés
autrefois ennemis
maintenant esclaves
et enfants
frères de Christ
aimés de Dieu
des gens
d'importance
au regard
de Christ
n'ayons pas peur
de le dire
nous avons de la valeur
aux yeux de Christ
vous ne devriez pas
être subjugués
être emportés
par la crainte
par l'anxiété
souvenez-vous
que Christ
est en train
d'annoncer
votre arrivée
devant la sainte
présence de Dieu
il est votre précurseur
jamais le rôle
de précurseur
n'a été prêté
au souverain
sacrificateur
du sacerdoce
terrestre
jamais
on a dit
le souverain
sacrificateur
devrait être
un précurseur
et quand il entre
dans le lieu très saint
il annonce notre arrivée
à Dieu dans le lieu très saint
jamais
si le peuple
était rentré
à la suite
du précurseur
nous serions tous
morts
foudroyés
dans le lieu très saint
terrestre
le fait que le souverain
la seule raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle
le souverain
sacrificateur
ne sort pas
du lieu très saint
c'est parce qu'il
est mort à l'intérieur
le souverain
sacrificateur
d'Israël
devait rentrer
et sortir
mais jamais communiquer
qu'il allait rentrer
et nous amener
avec nous
Christ lui
est présenté
comme notre souverain
sacrificateur
en tant que précurseur
et lorsqu'il entre
dans la gloire
il annonce
que nous allons
marcher à sa suite
également
il annonce
que tout son peuple
pourra rentrer
dans les portes
du paradis
et il annonce ça
devant la face
de Dieu
c'est un rôle
tout à fait unique
que le rôle de précurseur
de Jésus Christ
en tant que prêtre
il n'est pas là
pour influencer Dieu
à notre sujet
quelque part
il est en train
de réclamer
un héritage
il est en train
de réclamer
le prix
de sa passion
il est en train
de réclamer
quelque chose
de juste
comptant sur la justice
de Dieu
à cause de ce qu'il a accompli
il est en train
de déclarer
notre arrivée
et tout ce qu'il demande
à cause de ce qu'il est
et ce qu'il a fait
est doux
et agréable
aux oreilles du Père
et nous pouvons
nous poser la question
qu'est-ce que Christ
a déclaré
déclare en notre sujet
en tant que précurseur
quel message
dit-il
à notre sujet
alors qu'il est devant
la très fin
très sainte face de Dieu
on pourrait imaginer
basé sur
des écrits
de la Bible
que j'ai tenté
de rassembler ici
et vous reconnaîtrez
certainement
les passages
les références bibliques
que la déclaration
en tant que précurseur
de Christ
ressemble
à ce type de message
j'ai libéré
ton peuple
du pouvoir
du péché
Père
j'ai libéré
les captifs
j'ai porté
leurs souffrances
je me suis chargé
de leurs douleurs
j'ai été frappé
par toi
j'ai été humilié
par les hommes
j'ai guéri
mon peuple
par mes meurtrissures
et tu as fait retomber
sur moi
leur iniquité
j'ai été
maltraité
opprimé
je n'ai pas ouvert
la bouche
et tu m'as brisé
par la souffrance
j'ai vaincu
Satan et la mort
j'ai dépouillé
les dominations
et les autorités
je les ai livrés
publiquement
en spectacle
en triomphant d'elles
à cause du travail
de mon âme
sois éternellement
rassasié
en me regardant
me voici
moi
et les enfants
que tu m'as donnés
voici la déclaration
de notre Christ
en tant que précurseur
du peuple de Dieu
il nous prépare
une place
lorsqu'il a traversé
le voile
il nous a préparé
une place
ce n'est plus
un message futur
comme si Dieu
Jésus était
continuellement
en train de travailler
et de compléter
son oeuvre
il nous a préparé
une place
votre place éternelle
est déjà prête
et si le Seigneur
vous reprend ce soir
soyez assurés
que votre place
est prête
votre demeure
il est le précurseur
celui qui a couru
avant nous
dans une course
pleine d'obstacles
de tentations
de trahison
de mépris
et nous qui sommes
invités
à courir
à sa suite
dans ce chemin
et dans cette course
nous pouvons regarder
à celui
qui a déjà
remporté le prix
nous pouvons regarder
à celui
qui a déjà
fini la course
et qui nous lie
par une chaîne
incassable
peu importe
nos circonstances
oui certainement
vous allez vous arrêter
et vous vous êtes
peut-être arrêté
dans cette course
oui certainement
vous avez déjà
trébuché
dans cette course
oui certainement
vous allez trébucher
dans cette course
et de la même
manière
que toute chose
est attirée
par la gravité
vers la terre
vous allez être
attiré
irrésistiblement
vers la demeure
céleste
de votre Dieu
parce que vous avez
votre précurseur
qui vous y attend
et qui vous y attire
sous ses pieds
demeure
l'encre
de vos âmes
il vous y attirera
sans faille
c'est la raison
pour laquelle
mes frères et sœurs
nous devrions marcher
avec audace
comme si notre demeure
était déjà prête
avec courage
peu importe
les afflictions
de ce monde
peu importe
l'hostilité
de ce monde
marchons
avec confiance
vers notre espérance
Jésus est le fondement
ultime
de votre espérance
et son office
en tant que prêtre
vient certifier
à tout jamais
votre triomphe
vous chrétiens
Amen